starting as a high school teacher who
helped win a Nobel Prize to becoming one
of the bloodiest drug kingpins in the
United States Walter White is one of the
most iconic characters on television and
for good reason
when we first meet Walter White in the
pilot episode it's hard to believe that
this mild-mannered and devoted chemistry
teacher husband and father could even
consider Walking On the Dark Side while
Walter's cancer diagnosis is his primary
incentive when he decides to break bad
it's later revealed that the trauma and
helplessness he experienced as a child
helped to mold him into who he was at
the start of the series control
particularly the kind which comes from
the projection of traditional masculine
strength is one of Walt's key motivators
growing up in the 1960s Walt never had a
strong Father Figure due to his father
suffering from sickness for as long as
he could remember as he would eventually
tell his son Walt Jr AKA Flynn Walt's
dad was diagnosed with Huntington's
disease when Walt was only four or five
years old his only memory of his father
is of a frightening hospital visit in
his dad's final days he can recall the
smells of the hospital and describes the
sight of his father as being all twisted
up possibly unable to recognize him this
event comes to Define how Walt wants to
project himself to his own son while he
battles his illness I don't want that to
be the memory you have of me when I'm
gone
with his Lifelong Love of science Walter
White seemed destined for greatness
during his college Years while a grad
student at the California Institute of
Technology he studied X-ray
crystallography and formed a close
friendship with fellow scientist Elliot
Schwartz together they formed the
company gray matter Technologies a name
inspired by combining their surnames
Schwartz is German for black and
combined with white gets us gray as the
company takes off the young chemists
file several patents as they continue
the research Walt's work as a
crystallography project leader would
even contribute to chemistry research
winning the Nobel Prize in 1985 and
accolades seen in the series pilot that
he still clinks two decades later
although Breaking Bad never explicitly
outlines the work that gray matter
Technologies was preoccupied with during
Walt's time with the startup a few Clues
can be found hidden in a Scientific
American cover and article framed on
Elliot's Library wall reading gray
matter Technologies closes in on the
molecular switch a molecular switch is a
nanoscale level device that turns on and
off like a light switch holding
tremendous implications for the future
of medicine while it's eventual ball
from an altruist helping Humanity to a
man who relishes manufacturing a deadly
drug only emphasizes the corruption of
his spirit
Walter White's transformation from
mild-mannered Science Guy to
Machiavellian meth manufacturer can look
like a Fall From Grace but he's been
repressing his darker side since long
before cooking his first batch of
Crystal something his former partners
Elliot and Gretchen try and eventually
fail to overlook like many narcissists
Walt has a way of maintaining
relationships without revealing the true
toxicity of his inner nature these
traits only emerge when he feels
threatened competitive or not fully in
control a hint of this inner darkness is
first revealed in Walt's relationship
with his gray matter colleagues
foreshadowing The Shakespearean downfall
to come as a young scientist Walt was
set on a course most could only dream up
as his business started to take off and
he became engaged to his lab assistant
Gretchen but after meeting her wealthy
family Walter abruptly broke things off
selling his share of the company for
measly five thousand dollars as Show
creator Vince Gilligan told Huffington
Post Gretchen's wealth kind of blew his
mind it made him feel inferior and he
overreacted he just kind of checked out
since the story is told from Walt's
perspective it can seem like Elliot and
Gretchen cut him out of the company and
profited from his ideas while leaving
poor walled out to dry it's an idea that
Walt is happy to perpetuate so much so
that the lawyer Saul Goodman and Better
Call Saul suggests Waltz sue the pair
wrongful termination intellectual
property theft uh patent fraud I mean I
could have sunk my teeth into this
Walt's impulsive departure from Gray
matter forever changes his path in life
but due to his tendency to Varnish his
personal history in a way that erases
his responsibility for his actions his
resentment towards Elliot and Gretchen
Groves after Walt's exit from the
company greymatter soared in value
eventually becoming a multi-billion
dollar Corporation by the start of
Breaking Bad to add insult to injury
Elliot and Gretchen became an item in
his absence whether it's because he's
too preoccupied with Envy or he truly
was the weakest link at greymatter while
its former colleagues Prosper while his
life shifts into neutral for a while he
continued in research working at a
handful of chemical Labs through the
years as he explains in the season 1
episode cancer man when Walt's crossword
puzzle sparked romance with restaurant
Hostess Skyler leads to marriage in a
kid he finds himself living what many
folks would see as the American dream a
stable job a family and home ownership
but for Walt's fragile ego his tepid
marriage middle class home and the
challenges of raising a son with
cerebral palsy never amounted to the
dream he sold off when he trades in his
research career for work as a high
school chemistry teacher while he
moonlights at a car wash it's as if he
resigned to a life of mediocrity and
resentment
the low water mark of Walt's life comes
with this cancer diagnosis a growing
physical symbol of his decaying Soul
which pushes him into a life of crime at
this point Walt's life has become one of
droning monotony he's self-condempt to
quietly absorb insults through his
gritted teeth while his family is
plagued by working class woes overdue
bills broken appliances and the added
pressure of another child on the way
even Walt's 50th birthday is a parade of
miseries his son's complaints his
disrespectful students and boss and a
party that seems more for Skyler where
he's upstaged by his brother-in-law
Hank's exploits as a DEA agent when Walt
receives his terminal diagnosis after
passing out at the car wash a day later
his blank reaction to his Bleak news
seems a logical extension of his General
numbness towards life but as that
information slowly sinks in it
short-circuits the filter holding back
Walt's rage and resentment aside that
first emerges when his boss asks him to
work late
wipe down this
with his looming death sentence
pressuring Walt to leave his family with
something to live on Walt starts to snap
out of his numb resignation but it's a
ride along with Hank during a DEA meth
bust that wakes him up to the
possibility of Breaking Bad it becomes
an act of rebellion against both the
literal and figurative impotence that
have defined his life since foolishly
selling his shares in Gray matter while
Financial pressure and family
obligations serve as Walt's official
reason for getting into the meth
business they're ultimately just his
excuse for rejecting the aggressively
beige role he settled into after all the
Genesis evolves foray into crime game
even before his cancer diagnosis when he
sees just how much cash Hank sees during
a raid in the pilot episode It's Easy
Money
till we catch you the diagnosis
liberates Walt bring him to embrace his
long repressed darker side when he
realizes his former student Jesse
Pinkman Cooks Crystal Walt finds himself
with both the excuse and the means to
get into the business even if he hasn't
really considered all of the
implications and risks after his
decision while it feels more energized
than he has in years he naively tells
Jesse he is awake and
uncharacteristically knocks down a
teenager for bullying his son the first
signs that dark Walt has been Unleashed
the next stage of Waltz transformation
is precipitated by external forces
thanks in large part to his own poor
judgment one of his fatal mistakes is
treating the meth business like gig work
that he can do for as long or as short
as he wants despite his Advanced
chemistry knowledge Walter lacks any
real sense of what drug production is
like especially when it comes to
interacting with dealers as every
character learns in any story about
organized crime there is simply no
dabbling in the drug business with his
mind set on a quick payday and the
thrill of doing something the old Walt
would have never attempted Walt
immediately finds himself in over his
head when he and Jesse are mistaken as
Stooges for the DEA by two vengeful
dealers he's forced to cook at gunpoint
suspecting he'll likely be killed as
soon as he's finished Walt throws
together some deadly phosphine gas to
get rid of his captors while this
homicidal Act of self-defense would
leave most people Sleepless and
traumatized it initially seems to ignite
Walt's libido and Empower him serving as
the first of many Grim milestones in his
long dark Journey
despite Walt's first kill libido boost
the distressing events around his first
cook leave him feeling somewhat trouble
when one of the dealers hit with the
phosphine gas Crazy 8 turns out to still
be alive Walt and Jesse are now saddled
with a seriously injured man who wants
to kill them while Walt and Jesse worry
about the other dealer's body
decomposing in the RV they secure Crazy
8 in Jesse's basement the irony being
that at this point they haven't made a
dine from actually selling math the fair
quickly realized that crazy 8 has to be
finished off but Walt finds this easier
said than done while he tries to work
through his moral Conflict by
brainstorming the pros and cons of
ending the drug dealer while it is
spared his burden when Crazy 8 tries to
kill him aware now that there's no going
back the Walt we see moving forward
becomes far less conflicted about the
ethical implications of his crimes
every Crime Boss needs a street name for
Walt his pseudonym Eisenberg becomes
something of a sentient alter ego which
gradually consumes him it's a name he
takes early on in his underworld career
inspired by the real-life theoretical
physicist Werner Heisenberg the name
quickly Finds Its way into a DEA
investigation in the season 2 episode
breakage Heisenberg I know
maybe it's a tweaker urban legend if
Walter White is Dr Jekyll Heisenberg is
his Mr Hyde as Walt continues his
descent into moral bankruptcy his
actions as Heisenberg become
increasingly more horrific he eventually
turns from his more justifiable violence
to more cold-blooded killings by the
time he poisons the child Brock in
season four to turn Jesse against the
Kingpin Gus and save his own skin Walter
White is no longer recognizable he's now
fully Heisenberg even if he's still
hanging on to the illusion of Walter
White science teacher and family man
after getting rid of Crazy 8 Walt's
Behavior toward Jesse and Skyler becomes
increasingly and unapologetically
abusive for a while he uses his cancer
diagnosis as a scapegoat for his actions
but as he gets deeper into the meth
business Walt's actions become more
unhinged things ultimately come to a
head after Skyla learns about his burner
phone in the season 2 episode ABQ up
until this point maltes performed his
share of unforgivable acts not the least
of which was allowing Jesse's girlfriend
Jane to die an act that would
inadvertently result in two passenger
planes colliding midair when Jane's
grieving father an air traffic
controller makes the Fatal mistake but
through it all Walt continues to feign
his old nice guy persona whenever it
suits him often compared to mentalizing
the darker aspects of his Jekyll and
Hyde personality in the season 4 episode
cornered Walt finally stops pretending
and reveals the truth to Skyler but she
doesn't fully understand how bad things
have gotten until Skyler suggests he's
in danger a guy opens his story and gets
shot and you think out of me
I am the one who knocks Walt ends up
striking a sort of deal with the Devil
with Skyler kicking off a cold war that
lasts the rest of their marriage
by the end of Breaking Bad Walter White
has murdered dozens either at his best
or by his own hands so to say he's
irredeemable there's something of an
understatement while it isn't quite
enough to fall under the category of
better late than never Walt does manage
to turn away from the Dark Side in his
final hours completing his
transformation into an arguably tragic
anti-hero like most narcissists Walt is
able to justify his actions throughout
the series but when he gets Hank killed
it serves as his belated wake-up call
marking the final turning point in
Walt's transformation even though it
wouldn't be fully realized until the
series second to last episode Granite
State after months on the Run Walt
phones the son Flynn in an effort to
arrange a money drop-off that would see
his vision for his family finally
realized but when struck by Flynn's
anger at Hank's death Walt decides to
turn himself into the police after
completing some final business after
arranging with Elliot and Gretchen to
take care of his family financially Walt
admits his true motivations to Skyler
telling her he selfishly did what he did
because it made him feel alive in Walt's
final moments after he kills his old
methylamine supplier Lydia with Bryson
and saves Jesse from a gang of Nazis he
lies down and dies in the meth lab
finally freeing the world from the
misery he's brought upon it